For some reason, 23 feels like a very big birthday to me.
I can't quite put my finger on exactly what it is.
It feels like I've lived multiple lives over the last five years.
I'm turning 18 to getting married,
having my first kid at 19.
Now, two kids later,
I'm turning 23. Feels like I finally found some footing
and found stuff I'm passionate about,
which I never really thought I would.
So much life has happened,
and I'm so grateful for every single year that passes.
We're currently on a little work trip in Paris.
So in between all the work stuff,
we're trying to find pockets of time dedicated to my birthday.
First thing on the agenda was Lucky's fitting
for this business of fashion gala that we're going to.
Tried on a bunch of options.
Whole team made sure that he got exactly what he wanted.
And after he landed on his suit,
we walked around Paris. Just one of my favorite things to do
before we headed back to our hotel to grab some lunch.
Not a huge fan of hotel food,
but this was actually really good.
Even though this pavlova was good,
I wanna get back home and back in my kitchen.
And my morning, I got a massage and got back into bed.